en quelques semaines il est devenu un
phénomène mondial
j'ai pété
j'ai pété j'ai pété aujourd'hui chat GPT
et la nouvelle star de l'intelligence
artificielle
[Musique]
en quelques mots chat GPT c'est un
logiciel d'intelligence artificielle si
on parle beaucoup de cet outil là c'est
qu'il est d'abord gratuit accessible sur
le web mais aussi parce qu'il répond à
toutes les questions mais vraiment avec
beaucoup d'assurance il donne
l'impression d'être un jeu c'est tout
[Musique]
il peut résumer un roman de mille pages
sans mot offrir des conseils financiers
bâtir un programme d'entraînement
physique ou bien créer un site web et
tout cela en moins de 3 secondes
sa réponse est écrite elle ne contient
donc aucune vidéo pas d'image ni de son
depuis sa mise en ligne 1000 choses ont
été dites sur ce nouvel outil
révolutionnaire inquiétant et même
menaçant
la réalité est certainement plus nuancée
pour y voir plus clair il n'y a pas
mille solutions il faut explorer chaque
gpti essayer de le comprendre
premier arrêt calcul Québec
Marie-Jean meurt la science informatique
derrière les prouesses de chat GPT n'a
aucun secret les fondements de ce qui
est utilisé aujourd'hui ce sont des
techniques qui sont connues depuis
longtemps ce qui révolutionnaire c'est
l'usage qui en effet c'est l'assemblage
qui en effet et qui aujourd'hui présente
quand même un résultat d'ingénierie qui
est tout à fait surprenant
contrairement au moteur de recherche
Google lorsque je questionne chat GPT sa
réponse ne fournit aucun lien à
consulter il m'offre plutôt une réponse
toute faite par exemple si je lui pose
une question teintée de préjugés il va
éviter de me fournir une réponse de
raciste ou homophobe même chose si je
lui demande de m'expliquer comment
dévaliser une bijouterie il est
impossible de voler une bijouterie sans
se faire arrêter par la police tout vole
est-il légal et puni par la loi comment
fait-il pour formuler une réponse
d'abord avant sa mise en ligne des
programmesurs lui ont fait gober des
quantités astronomiques d'informations
essentiellement des pages Web sa banque
de données contient 300 milliards de
mots et d'expression des humains l'ont
donc guidé à formuler ces réponses
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien on va
fournir des contenus textuels très
offensants
à plein niveau ça peut être de la
violence ça peut être du sexisme ça peut
être des contenus illégaux même enfin
décrivant des choses illégales on va
fournir ces contenus
à des humains et on va leur dire à noter
s'il vous plaît ces contenus c'est à
dire mettez-leur une petite étiquette
qui dit attention ça ça va pas durant
son développement tchat j'ai pété a
forcément été exposé à de l'information
biaisée douteuse ou même fausse à partir
du moment où on a on fait apprendre un
outil sur des données existantes qui
elle-même sont teintées par nos biais
puisque elles ont été produites par des
humains et que nous sommes tous capables
de produire des contenus biaisés
puisqu'on a tous chacun notre façon nous
bien partir du moment où c'est ces
outils sont entraînés sur des textes
biaisés
il reproduisent potentiellement c'est
bien
[Musique]
après des mois d'entraînement il peut
maintenant générer une réponse en moins
de 3 secondes cette vitesse est rendue
possible grâce à une puissance de calcul
impressionnante mais aussi grâce aux
mathématiques plus précisément au monde
des probabilités
à la question pourquoi une personne âgée
devrait-elle faire de l'activité
physique l'algorithme détermine dans son
modèle où se trouve cette suite de mots
et combien de fois et l'apparaît il
analyse aussi le contexte dans lequel
ces mots se retrouvent pour ensuite le
comparer au contexte similaire chaque
assemblage de mots est une probabilité
qui passe à travers des millions de
paramètres pour que la réponse soit
cohérente l'algorithme tient toujours
compte de les changer en cours
tchat GPT ne répond pas aux questions
d'actualité parce que ces données ne
sont pas mises à jour en temps réel
par curiosité je lui ai demandé quand
même de m'expliquer pourquoi les
États-Unis avaient abattu un ballon
chinois en février 2023 contre toute
attente il me répond des sources
affirment que le ballon chinois était
abattu parce qu'il survolait une zone
sensible et pouvait être considérée
comme une menace potentielle pour la
sécurité nationale américaine mais ça
vous l'avez testé vous-même dans la
version gratuite de chat GPD
qui a été trouvé sur le net c'est sûr
donc il y a des contenus qui ont été
ajoutés c'est très probable donc
effectivement sur des sujets
probablement un peu brûlants des ajouts
ont pu être fait récemment mais sur des
sujets qui sont moins pertinents il est
très probable que ça soit des domaines
totalement ignorés du modèle parfois
tchat GPT déraille invente carrément des
réponses
erronées son petit côté je sais tout en
prend vraiment pour son rhume mais ce
n'est pas vraiment surprenant parce que
la qualité des réponses n'est jamais
garantie le développement des contenus
on est très très loin de
de la validation on est très loin de
d'un outil qui va pouvoir générer des
choses auxquelles on peut faire
confiance le fait qu'il puisse se
tromper mettent en lumière l'importance
du doute et du sens critique on pourrait
se dire c'est la fin de la pensée c'est
la fin de l'acte réflexif etc
c'est faux parce que au contraire il est
absolument indispensable quand on est
face à des contenus produits par chat
dgpt d'avoir encore plus d'esprits
critiques et encore plus de d'approches
réflexives que ce que l'on a lorsque
l'on utilise les résultats d'un moteur
de recherche comme par exemple les
résultats de Google
[Musique]
l'arrivée de tchat GPT ne laisse
personne indifférent et le milieu de la
santé ne fait pas exception pour savoir
si l'intelligence artificielle peut
servir d'outils de taux diagnostic on a
soumis trois scénarios au docteur
Mathieu Pelletier omnipraticien du
nombre une personne diabétique dont la
glycémie est mal contrôlée non non
je suis impressionné parce que ça a
vraiment une conversation la machine se
prononce le comme si comme si elle était
donnée des conseils ça peut devenir très
crédible très crédible on dirait qu'elle
maîtrise le sujet c'est vraiment mais
elle ne le maîtrise pas comme un
clinicien comme une infirmière qui peut
poser des questions complémentaires à
son patient je pense que j'ai pété
pourrait être utile peut-être pour
donner de l'information factuelle en
réponse à une question d'un patient sur
un sujet comme par exemple
est-ce que vous pourriez m'expliquer les
signes et symptômes d'une pneumonie donc
le médecin de famille en vous ne se sent
absolument pas menacé
le médecin de famille en moi ne sent pas
menacé mais j'ai une inquiétude pour mes
patients quand je vois ça parce que je
suis impressionné par le scénario la
discussion qui coule et je pense que des
patients pourraient se fier à Jean de
choses là ça m'inquiète
[Musique]
je suis un peu gêné de le dire mais
parfois tchatchepetti me donne
l'impression d'être
empathique il glisse dans ses réponses
des petits mots du genre je suis désolé
n'hésite pas à consulter aux besoins
prends soin de toi
Manon Tanguy et psychologue elle
s'intéresse à la relation entre les
robots et les humains je lui ai montré
mon échange avec chat GPT un échange au
cours duquel je demande des conseils
pour aider un homme de 70 ans des primés
qui éprouvent aussi des problèmes de
mémoire et d'alcool ce qui m'a rassuré
c'est qu'on a
pas le temps de faire un diagnostic pour
l'excès fort intéressant parce que ça
oriente et c'est ce qu'on souhaite aussi
je trouve ça plus rassurant je vous
dirais que ce que les gens ont tendance
à faire quand ils vont sur les réseaux
sociaux pour essayer d'aller chercher
des gens qui à quelque part oui moi j'ai
déjà vécu ça mon père vécu ça parce que
là on se met à faire des amalgames avec
toutes sortes de situations qui ont
absolument pas à part
malgré ces défauts tchatchepetti
impressionnent mais peut-on dire que
l'outil est intelligent capable de
réfléchir non on ne parle pas
d'intelligence non on ne parle pas de
compréhension on n'est pas là du tout
pour dire ça plus simplement c'est un
outil qui ne comprend pas il n'y a pas
de compréhension dans chat GPT il y a
une production de contenu mais il n'y a
pas de compréhension
[Musique]
en mars dernier on a fait une mise à
jour de chat GPT on a amélioré son taux
de bonnes réponses d'environ 40%
. il peut dorénavant récupérer de
l'information sur le web pour enrichir
ces réponses face à la puissance de ces
robots des experts s'inquiètent est-ce
qu'une réflexion s'impose plusieurs
chercheurs le souhaitent
janvier 2007 à l'époque c'est Jobs
présentent le premier iPhone c'est le
début d'une révolution depuis l'appareil
intègre le téléphone le GPS le guichet
automatique l'appareil photo la télé
bref un peu tout
est-ce que Tchad JPP va devenir tour à
tour un médecin un psychologue et un
avocat à cette question l'outil se fait
plutôt rassurant non chat gpti n'est pas
conçu pour remplacer un médecin un
psychologue ou un avocat
[Musique]